narcotráfico cierto es un actor del
conflicto que más Gilberto da una clase
de memoria histórica temario que ha
llegado de forma pionera a las escuelas
de la alcaldía de Bogotá la historia de
muchos de estos estudiantes también está
marcada por el conflicto que a veces
llegamos a cuestionar muchas cosas de
desplazado Uy Este es un mural sobre el
conflicto elaborado por los alumnos del
colegio de eleazapata se hizo en 2022
con motivo de la publicación del informe
de la comisión de la verdad que rinde
cuenta de las dinámicas del conflicto
durante cinco décadas el gobierno de
Gustavo Petro y Francia Márquez ha
prometido implementarlo en su sistema
educativo es el primer ejecutivo de
izquierda en la historia de Colombia y
el primero de este tipo en representar
al país en la celac un giro que llega
hasta el estudio de la propia historia
enseñarles a ellos es construir un
futuro de cambio y de paz
después de 13 años en 2022 también hubo
cambio en Honduras con la proclamación
de Xiomara Castro como presidenta por lo
que la celac volverá a contar con la
presencia de un gobierno de izquierda en
Centroamérica una de sus principales
apuestas ha sido desde el deporte
remodelando decenas de instalaciones el
objetivo es reinsertar a niños y jóvenes
en riesgo por consumo de drogas
vinculación con maras y con el fin de
frenar la migración un ejemplo esa
bielsa gastumé que practica Kendo karate
muchos jóvenes se ha notado que han
hecho la diferencia han marcado una
diferencia saliendo mucho de alguna
adicción del alcohol de las drogas
[Música]
Erika Hilton es una de las dos primeras
diputadas trans en la historia de Brasil
el país donde más personas de este
colectivo son asesinadas en el mundo
según datos de la ONU tras la ausencia
en la última celac del gobierno de James
bolsonaro Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva
devuelve a Brasil a la Cumbre y las
esperanzas a las diversidades
estamos reconstruyendo la narrativa de
la sociedad está claro Un gobierno de
izquierda facilita que esta agenda
avance pero nosotras llegamos antes del
gobierno Erika Hilton por el rechazo
familiar tuvo que vivir en la calle a
los 15 años seis años después retomó los
estudios y se incorporó al movimiento
estudiantil hoy desde la cámara seguirá
su lucha en un Brasil que igual que gran
parte de América Latina ha girado a la
izquierda